alors sur les trois modèles c'étaient
les patrons que tu avais fait le rap et
bain par exemple tu as le la petite le
petit tu as le chat et tu as le lapin
proches savent combien les nouveaux
modèles viennent d'être validées martin
9 ans a donné son feu vert
car c'est bien lui le créateur et le
designer de ces doudous fabriqués ici
dans cet atelier d'insertion de
l'association coop agir c'est là que le
petit garçon est venu il ya deux ans à
porter des vêtements collectés dans son
école à la regarde martin va regarder
les prix oui on 0 on s'était dit martin
il a voulu amener des vêtements dans nos
ateliers entre on traite 400 tonnes de
vêtements par an donc les 40 kg qui l'a
amené c'était une contribution mais une
contribution qui avait du sens avec une
belle histoire et qui nous a amené
jusque jusqu'au 12 car faire appel à la
générosité de ses copains de classe ne
lui suffisait pas alors pour apporter un
peu de douceur aux enfants de migrants
martin s'est mise à la couture et à
créer ces doudous à vendre ou à
distribuer du désir pour les petits
enfants de migrants qui à cause de la
guerre ou ou de la misère et bien ils
ont
ils ont migré et je trouve que c'est
difficile je pense qu'ils demandent aux
adultes de se bouger de se réveiller de
sortir un peu de nos individualisme
parfois de nos égoïsmes et martin il a
toute sa place avec le le début de
l'histoire et le choc pour martin
c'était ici place granvelle à besançon
il y a deux ans quand en sortant de
l'école
il a découvert que des migrants
dormaient sous des tentes insupportable
pour lui si gâtés par la vie
tiens ça me rappelle le départ des deux
doux et ben on sortait de l'école on
allait chercher la voiture et on a vu un
paquet tentes ou des migrants vivaient y
avait des bébés et des enfants
on a commencé à le ramener à manger et
des couches pour les bébés et on a
commencé à perdre et de doux c'est là
que l'histoire est née
mertens un petit garçon qui est très
sensible qui est toujours là pour les
autres
et puis en fait il était très affecté de
voir que des gens vivent est dehors et
surtout des enfants surtout des bébés
qu'ils avaient rien et puis aussi
prendre conscience que lui il avait
beaucoup de choses j'ai des choix et des
eaux des deschiens des désirs ondes et
les perroquets les étire les baleines
un doudou c'est pour mieux dormir et si
tu as des problèmes c'est pour pas tu
peux par exemple lui raconter des
problèmes c'est ça pour moins de nous
démarquer espérant un peu de douceur
dans un monde de violence et un mot
choisi par martin pour être brodé sur
chacun de ces doudous espoirs dans
toutes les langues